Hey everybody, Doug Walker here.
I'm sick.
Um...
I'm getting a lot better,
Uh...
Actually, I've gotten a lot better, we're going to film
the review, probably while you're watching this,
I'm filming, uh, the next review. But sadly, that means no editorial today,
What we're gonna do about it is,
The editorial is written, I just, I couldn't film it.
So I'm gonna film it NEXT week, so it's still gonna be tied into Sequel Month
It's just gonna be, you know, on a delay. So the review is still coming out next week, and
the editorial for Sequel Month will come out the week after.
And after that, we'll just go back to sorta the normal Nostalgia Critics.
It was the Norovirus.
Which I have never had before, and I've had stomach flus before, but this...
This was the worst, this was awful and literally, the morning I woke up,
My wife did some research on it, and just,
Apparently everyone got it at the exact same morning I did, cause it was on the news,
It was spreading like wildfire, and it's super contagious.
I had to do something I never done before,
I had to cancel a Con.
Kami-Con I had to cancel sadly.
Which I felt so bad for, cause I was building it up and everything,
And a lot of other people here got sick.
My brother got sick, and Tamera got sick, so...
I'm so, so sorry and it really sucks, but:
A) I was feeling awful, and  B) I didn't want to contaminate other people at the
convention cause apparently this like, UBER-contagious. So...
Yeah, you know the set-up now, and I'm so sorry I couldn't get you an editorial this week,
But it will be up two weeks from now, and the regular review, "Garfield 2",
That's still gonna be up a week from today, so um, guys I'm already feeling better,
So I've no need for the well wishes or anything,
Just giving you a heads up on what's going on.
So that's about it and hope all is well,
And I'll talk to you later, bye!